hello everyone and welcome to what is
probably the craziest game of the
tournament so far we are in the second
game of the aimchs u.s rapid knockouts
the finals magnus cross and versus laris
lavartem and magnus won his game with
the black pieces and now artemis has to
find a way in the next three games to to
kind of get back into the match so like
i said this one uh craziest so far let's
check it out everything is hanging in
this game magnus has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 uh we have d5
bartimiev c4 we have e6 knight to c3 and
c5 going for the taj defense we have c
captures on d5 by magnus e captures on
d5 and now d captures on c5 uh artemiev
advances the pawn we have d4 knights to
a4 and now uh the most played move here
it is considered best for black that is
b5 challenging this knight as the knight
doesn't really have a good square so
white will have to capture our passage
and uh continue the game in that style
so we have c characters and b6 alpha a
capture sun b6 uh in the now b3 and this
is the position where artemis already
lost quite a lot of time magnus played
pretty much everything instantly but
also artemia uh disconnected uh
from the internet in this uh
position right here and uh his time ran
out to zero uh but of course he did not
lose in time after he reconnected he was
given back his time and then the game
continued from here but already uh quite
an quite an interesting game
but artemis is very much uh down on the
clock uh so here we have b5 challenging
the knight and the knight now has to go
back we have knight back to b2 uh and
here you could go for some like knight
f6 you could go knight to c6 but the
move artemia plays is a new move so
bishop to be for check and it is as of
move 9 that we have a completely new
game uh here magnus blocks this bishop
to d2 we have bishop captures and d2
queen captures and now knight to f6
artemia would be very happy to castle as
he does need to start developing his
pieces uh but magnus starts with e4 he
opens up this bishop's attack towards
the pawn so he wants to develop with
temple bishop captures on b5 this would
come with check and then maybe even
start an attack against the black king
yeah but artemis not afraid although he
could just castle here he goes for
knight captures on e4 bravely attacks
carlson's queen here uh magnus goes
bishop captures and b5 with check bishop
to d7 and now queen to b4 uh guarding
his bishop but also preventing artemis
king from castling we have knight to c3
now uh an excellent square for the
knight here uh but now bishop captures
on d7 the knight is attacked twice or
the bishop is attacked twice so you have
to react to this you could go back with
bishop to d3 but magnus trades here we
have bishop captures and d7 with czech
queen captures and now uh you have to do
something about your king still being in
the center of the board uh if you try
knight to f3 uh that doesn't really
do all that much as for example knight
to c6 attacks the white queen and it's
going to be
it's just going to be very messy here so
instead after this queen captures on d7
we have kinked the f1 by magnus and now
the rook can come to e1 and attack
the black king here so knights the c6
attacking the queen rook to e1 with
check and now if you block here then
this knight will remain here for a very
very long time it's uh well you can't
defend it you can't really
castle uh and uh well it's it's just not
maybe not the greatest of positions why
can play h4 bring the rook quickly into
the game uh so he he decides against
this he plays king to d8 sidesteps this
and now uh neither of them can castle we
have queen to b6 uh delivering a check
from here queen to c7 offering a queen
trait and queen back to c5 so of course
keeping the queens on the board uh and
now artemis has to decide what to do
here again he could go for something
like rook to e8 but he goes for the pawn
grab and why not he says all right there
really is no danger here we have rook
capture 72 attacking carlson's knight
here and now uh carlson is in trouble
unless he finds the absolute strongest
move that um uh saves him
saves him the game and it's not easy
doing this uh it's very interesting
which move would you play it's uh really
crazy stuff uh because uh knight the d3
is with the way to go and it doesn't
lose you the game but knight the c4
loses you the game and it's uh it seems
like knight to c4 is the move you want
to play because the knight is a bit more
active and closer to the black king but
just to show you how fun chess can be uh
rook to e8 we attack white rook on e1
and now it doesn't really matter white
can continue development knight to f3
but now we're just gonna capture rook
capture sunny one knight captures and
now this very unpleasant move rook
captures on f2 and that's the reason why
the knight belongs on d3 to guard the if
the df2 square and if king captures just
knight to e4 check would pick up the
white queen that's that's beautiful so
magnus spots this he plays knight to d3
guarding the f2 pawn and now we have to
continue the game rook to e8 and magnus
continues developing knight to f3 so the
rook is now nicely defended by both
knights
we've now of course the same idea can't
work because the knight covers the f2
pawn so rook to a5 attacking the queen
here queen to c4 and now artemis trades
rook captures on e1 knight d captures an
e1 and here we have queen to d7
uh activating the queen a little bit
more maybe with some ideas of pushing
the past pawn but also just uh queen to
d5 is possible offering a queen trade
now the problem for artemia again is
that magnus has some seven minutes on
the clock rtm is already on the one
minute mark and he decides that uh well
after magnus played h4 of course he
wants to get his rook somehow into the
game uh artemyev decides that maybe it's
best to avoid any further complications
like rook day one seems to keep the
tension and everything but he plays
queen to d5 he says all right i'm
legistrate queens and i'm going to be
very safe in the end game against magnus
so here magnus continues to rook to h3
develop his rook also you want to keep
an eye on that d3 square sufficiently uh
you don't want the black to just start
pushing this pawn and now artemis trades
we have queen captures on c4 b captures
on c4 and now rook to a4 going after
this pawn
but this doesn't really work uh magnus
just picks up the d4 pawn so knight
captures on d4 and now although you can
pick up the knight the knight and c3 is
hanging so artemis just picks up the the
pawn on c4 uh and here we have knight to
f5 moving the knight away from
this rook but uh
and attacking the g7 pawn but it's
really really amazing what uh
lurks in this position is artemia was a
really low on clock some 15 seconds on
the clock and he played g6 but this move
completely loses the game for him so
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find this idea while i give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
incredibly uh you know present move and
for those who just want to enjoy the
show rook the d3 check is fine but the
absolute strongest is knight to d6 this
is what magnus played and he was in this
position unknown 29 that vladislav
resigned in the game and the magnus now
takes the lead two to zero in their uh
match in the finals so the problem is
the rook is attacked here and if you
move it uh for example to c5 you're just
gonna run into this fork knight b7 check
wins the rook and if you move it
somewhere else uh then these knights are
uh well just gonna fall and if you try
something like rook to d4 to try and
trade knights white will first move the
knight with check and then after the
king moves we're just gonna pick up the
knight and now of course if black picks
up the knight we're gonna pick up the c6
knight as well and we're gonna be up a
night
uh so yeah uh tough break for artemia
loses the second game as well and now he
has to win two games in a row
just to tie the first match which is not
not a small feat but for a player of his
skills definitely uh possible so we'll
see what happens uh but this really just
an impressive game how magnus avoided
this trick where he had to find the the
knights the d3 id and not to go too
active with the knight and allow rook
captures on f2 and then just grinding
down artemis in the endgame uh just well
very very unpleasant uh experience for
for our team so far uh so yeah that's
the game i hope you guys enjoyed it
we're going to continue uh with the
coverage of the of the finals uh i would
like to thank uh happy birthday shahrukh
christopher alexander sofa uh tom derelo
caked
and vinci natalie for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the finals uh
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day